il y à un oeuf qui fait gagner un week
end à tout le public
merkel
il ya un week-end pour deux à marrakech
gagner
[Applaudissements]
je vous lis pas les roues le
génial
terrain
les chéris c'est très simple je vous le
dis moi je sais où est le cadeau pour le
public
vous allez choisir chacun un oeuf
et
c'est très simple celui moi je sais
qu'elle est la moitié nom de celui qui
aura la boîte gagnante pourra faire
gagner tout le public l'accord
chacun votre tour vous allez me dire
l'offre que vous prenez guillaume cette
non je sais que c'est toi c'est au moins
le beau 6 mai le shisha selon les
statistiques on va tous les ouvrir alors
je vous dis étant donné qu'on est très
en retard on va ouvrir que lov gagnant
c'est sûr alors non ah non pas non parce
qu'on va savoir qui est ce que quelle
est la personne qui va faire gagner tout
puis il aura un défi
je sais ce que lui
alors oui oui et que tu veux dire un
défi
excuse moi
[Applaudissements]
déclaré
que tu veux gallas et evra l'ofs le 3e
avant le 5 mai chiffres
précis
[Applaudissements]
il a déjà beaucoup disent que tu as
trouvé
libre à vous de voir désolé mais
regagner des oeufs de pâques à tout le
public ouais
[Applaudissements]
on est là c'est parti
[Rires]
c'est très bien mais j'ai pris ton temps
m'a bien
moi je vais vous dire il va faire gagner
aussi séjour à marrakech pour des
personnes que qui seront donc plus on
pas les roule c'est extraordinaire fait
chier ça je
[Rires]
découvre et remercier un grand maître
chocolatier belge d'accord du coup on
joue plus avec les non plus personne
jour
je vais vous faire gagner tout le public
le public gagne également le c'est loin
pas cacher que c'est très simple il est
recommandé car ce qui a été choisi par
le matin
[Applaudissements]
mais dans ces instances je vous dirai
quel défi
bertrand et qui est ce que quand je
crois que tu deviens le défi maintenant
way bertrand max est très simple tu vas
devoir trouver l'oeuf magique tu vas
suivre le twitt alexandre guérini qui va
t'amener à l'offre magique tu as
exactement trente secondes pour trouver
le magic l'a léon bertrand vas-y
[Applaudissements]
des
ah ah
l'ouganda
[Rires]
écoute
il
[Applaudissements]
les jeunes
arrêté le pauvre merci tout va bien les
chéris bravo
[Applaudissements]
sarah 3000 noms publics du chocolat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]